ROY FULLER: OK,
ready to roll, Ajaya.
We are now recording.
AJAYA GUMMADI: Thank
you so much, Roy.
Welcome, everyone.
Thank you so much
for being here today.
I am Ajaya.
I'm a Solution Manager
within the Google Cloud Team.
And my role here is to solve
problems that customers
may have with the data, OK?
Not that anyone has ever.
We have a full
half an hour to us.
I would recommend get
your choice of beverage
for this time of the day or
whenever you are listening,
and let's get started.
We will have time
for Q&A at the end.
So I do want to present or
at least give you pointers.
And then we'll engage
in the Q&A, OK?
You can quote me on
this code-- "behind
every successful
application, there
is a great database
powering it."
And this is my code.
It's my favorite saying.
And my next favorite
saying is, "Applications
go wherever the data resides."
It's the data that creates
applications' stickiness
to a platform.
You may start with
data monetization
or without monetization,
but just don't stop at one,
but rather let one
drive the other, OK?
Now, what's happening
in the data world--
and we have been saying the
same story for a long time.
Data is just growing and
growing and growing, OK?
It's growing in volume.
It's growing in its
velocity and the variety--
the same old story, right?
And now it's growing more with
all the digital transformation
that's happening, which is
propelled by the COVID, OK?
I was looking at the
fintech industry.
It's one of the largest
vertical segments that we have.
It's handling 100 trillion
transactions a day
from around 20,000 financial
institutions worldwide.
And that's also unfortunately
driving the rise
in cybersecurity attacks.
And there's a report from FBI
around how that has increased.
Now, that's a
number we don't want
where it is right now
and directionally where
the number is going.
We are also seeing that
customers are coming
to Cloud in different patterns.
Some are coming just as
is for reducing the costs.
So they're taking their existing
databases, moving it as is.
We call those homogeneous
database migrations.
And this could be
your existing Oracles
and SQL server, or even in the
open source world, your MySQL
and PostgreSQL.
So you bring it as is to
Cloud, run it in the Compute,
or you take it to
the Managed Services.
That's definitely one
pattern that we are seeing.
As customers get
familiar with Cloud,
some move on to the next step.
And they say, I'm
going to break away
from these legacy databases and
use a cloud-native database.
And that's another pattern.
But really, the pattern that has
picked up within the last year
is that customers
are saying, we really
want to try out a
new business model.
We know the power of Cloud.
We know the power of the
Google Cloud-native databases.
And we want to transform
our customer experience.
We have solutions for all
these three customer journeys.
There's migration
solution that will help
you migrate your databases.
There's modernization
solutions that
will help you do a
heterogeneous database
modernization, for example,
from MySQL to Spanner or Oracle
to Spanner.
And then really, what
today's focus in my talk
will be on transformation,
where the customers are
trying to redesign their
business models, OK?
So I lost something here.
Let me turn off that.
Sorry.
So on the transformation side,
when we speak with customers,
they have told us,
we love to work
with the Cloud-native databases.
But we don't have
that critical mass
of developers who can develop
a workload, a new workload,
a new transformative
workload, using
those Cloud-native databases.
And yes, our
migration cycles are
long because it's not just
flipping the switch over
to database.
We got to look at the
application ecosystem.
We got to test it.
We got to certify it.
We got to make sure our
compliances are all there.
So this becomes kind of a
9 to 12-month cycle, right?
And then it's like, what can we
do to have something quicker?
So they asked us for help.
And yes, indeed, we gave help.
So this is the build
with Google's solution
from Google Cloud.
Basically in this
solution, we are giving you
the building blocks.
So think of it like
if you were building
a next-generation spaceship.
You can build it with the
smallest brick, the smallest
block from LEGO or
anyone else, right?
And you will get there.
It will be a slow journey.
You will have some fallbacks.
You will have some
risk to undertake.
But eventually,
you'll get there.
But what if you got
some prebuilt wings
of that spaceship or
engine or the nose.
And these prebuilt
hardened components,
you could use as is.
You could customize them
for your specifications.
That will help you build
a spaceship faster, right?
It will accelerate
your journey there.
And also, because these
prebuilt components
are from a vendor
like Google, it
will mitigate your risk
because these are hardened.
These are tested blocks.
Now, think of a
database application
instead of the
next-generation spaceship.
Every database application
has need to ingest data.
Then it has a need to make
sure the data is secure.
It has a need to
process the data.
analyze the data,
archive, delete, put
it on a dashboard.
Those are like
common data services
that every application, every
database application needs.
And what happens today is that
as customers start building,
they have to build all of that.
And this is what Build
with Google is doing.
It's handing over those
prebuilt blocks to the customers
so that they can accelerate
the journey to the cloud, OK?
So in [INAUDIBLE]
first use case has been
how to build a payment gateway.
And we'll go over what
a payment gateway is,
and we'll look at the
architecture for that.
But basically,
this was a request
from our retail customers.
One of the common problems
of a retail customer
is the abandonment of the cart.
And I've been guilty of
that as much as anyone else
when I have to give my
credit card information
and my address, 25 clicks.
I'm like, oh, forget it.
I'm not going to buy from here.
70% of the customers abandon
their cart at checkout,
and this is true for
the brick stores as well
as online stores.
And if you go and
talk to any retailer,
they will give you
the exact dollar
amount that it costs them, OK?
So that's a pure retail problem.
But then that
problem also extends
into the financial sectors
where the traditional banks
are looking for their
next million customers.
And they're coming to Google,
and we have only just a few,
to say, apps with billions
of customers using them.
And they're looking for
some new applications that
will get all the attention of
those millennial customers,
make them loyal customers
while being compliant.
Compliance is a very,
very important thing
in financial industry.
So our payment gateway use
case has a proven reference
architecture that's been
built on top of the learnings
from our own Google Payments.
If you have ever been
a customer of Google,
whether Google Play, YouTube,
or a Cloud subscription,
any financial transaction that
you would have done with Google
runs on that Google
Payments platform.
So we have gone and
learned from that
and incorporated those learnings
in that reference architecture
and make sure that we shared
it with the customer using
the Google Cloud
technologies like Spanner.
Now, this Google
Payment handles hundreds
of millions of transactions.
It runs in 200-plus
countries around the world,
handling multiple
currencies, doing compliance
across all these countries, so
financial reporting, compliance
reporting, treasury reporting,
currency hedging, all of that.
Now, we have taken a
small component of it,
and I'll go over that in a
short while with all of you.
The next use case is
basically a data fabric.
By the way, the payment
gateway reference architecture
is available today,
the version 1 of it.
For version 2, we
are doing more work,
pulling together the
data abstraction layer,
also double [INAUDIBLE] into
the risk management system,
and also put in some blueprints.
So we'll go over those shortly.
But let me introduce our second
use case before we move on,
and that's building
a data fabric, right?
So a lot of banks,
as they are trying
to implement the open
banking standards,
they need to move fast, right?
Customers in retail and
manufacturing need to have
a real-time view of their
entire supply chain,
not just one part of it,
but the whole thing--
supply chain, warehouse,
their partners,
their suppliers, down to the
root, right-- and the order
view and what's selling
their view, right?
If you walk into a store and
see an out-of-stock item, that's
a lot of lost sales for
that retailer, right?
And every retailer will
tell you exactly the dollar
amount of it.
But not just in retail,
telecom service providers,
as you subscribe to a plan,
the call detail record
tells a lot about
your calling patterns
and can give the telecom service
provider some real insights
into fraud and prevent those
fraud across the globe, OK?
So having that CDR, having
the health care provider have
a 360-degree view of the
patients in real time--
these are some of the needs
coming from our customers.
And what we have
with the data fabric
is a proven reference
architecture
with building blocks for
the common data services
so that we reference
architecture
that record snippets
available in a Google Cloud
repo, documentation,
installation
scripts, and in
some cases a sandbox
where you can come
and play with this.
These common data services
will help you do data ingestion
in real time, catalog
management, metadata
management, data
discovery, data lineage
integration with
security services,
integration with analytics
and dashboard and reporting
services, using the Google
Cloud-native databases.
And then once you have
that infrastructure,
we expect the customers to just
focus on their vertical use
case, their business logic when
they want to build that fraud
application.
They don't have to worry about
these common data services.
They get that from
the data fabric.
They have to worry
about, what's my logic?
What are my rules?
What are my triggers to do
fraud alerts, to do an order,
to do a pricing promotion, any
of those vertical use cases?
For the gaming segment, we plan
to publish some code templates.
We're using Spanner
and Firestore
for the retail apart from
real-time recommendations
and personalizations,
order management,
inventory management, a
view of the supply chain.
So today, we are going
out with financial use
cases and retail use cases.
But we are also keeping our
eye on health care and life
sciences for a patient 360, CDR
store for telecommunications,
bill of materials
for manufacturing.
Just watch this space.
There's a lot coming in.
Let me move on to
the payments gateway.
For those of you who
have used payments,
any credit card, debit
card-- it gets acquired.
You may be doing a
point-of-sale terminal.
It will get acquired, and
then processing happens.
And then it gets handed
over to a payments
processor, which will then work
with the payer bank and payee
bank to settle that transaction.
So there are a lot of
components behind this
which make this happen.
And things like when you
acquired the transaction,
the very first thing
we do is to encrypt it
because it has your PII, right?
You don't want to show that
credit card in real time.
And then you would have
some orchestration services.
You will be provisioning the
users, verifying the users.
The payment management
system will be going deeper
into the payment transaction.
It will be doing some risk
assessment in real time,
whether to approve
the transaction
or deny it, or maybe cap
it based on your profile.
All of this is
happening and getting
stored in a secure data
storage which is PCI compliant
before it gets handed over
to the payment processor, OK?
So between these two vertical
lines, everything in between
is the scope of a
payments gateway
for which we have put
together the reference
architecture for
you to use it with
deep technical documentation.
In this reference
architecture, we
are using GKE for all
the application services,
and we are using Cloud Spanner
for all your database needs
because as you will
see, the tenets that we
had for this design
around security,
around availability,
around consistency,
the only product
in Cloud that could
meet it was Cloud Spanner.
So talking about design
tenets, what we had was--
first and foremost, it was
the PCI compliance, right?
And basically, it was to
maintain the secure network,
maintain the cardholder
data, monitor it--
who's accessing what,
log it, and audit it.
But apart from security
itself, it also
needs to be highly available
because you need access
to your money at all times.
And your transaction needs to
have total integrity, right?
If you are doing a
transaction for $40,
it better not be $40.0001, OK?
And then have performance,
and not only performance,
but performance at scale, the
throughput and the latency,
and then the manageability
aspects, the backup,
and the restore verification
and the disaster recovery.
And it should be able to scale
up and down as your scale
increases or you go through
a quiet period, right?
All of that.
So Cloud Spanner was
the only database
that we could find which met
all of those design tenets.
It gave us security
and compliance
out of the box, DLP, ANSI
SQL, very, very strong
external consistency, scale
of petabytes of database
with performance, distributed,
strong consistency, very simple
administration,
online schema changes,
five-nines availability with the
architecture that I'm sure you
have heard about, RPO = 0.
In a financial, in any of
these transactional industry,
you cannot, cannot
lose any data, OK?
And failure recovery,
and on a global scale,
but with multiregions.
On the security and
compliance side,
the shared responsibility
model, very well
documented on our website.
For PCI DSS, how do
you isolate the data?
How do you encrypt at
rest and in transit?
How do you manage your
keys with KMS and HSM?
How do you do logging?
Who is doing what and
audit and monitor and do
the PCI-DSS-compliant templates?
Spanner integrates with IAM
for fine-grained access.
It integrates with
VPC-SC to achieve
isolation of cardholder data.
It encrypts the data.
You can manage your
keys with the CMEK
and also audit logging
and monitoring.
I'm going a little bit faster,
keeping an eye on the time.
There are these PCI DSS
blueprints available
today for PCI on GKE
and Anthos, and Spanner
is coming very soon.
You will see it announced.
On the scale and
availability, I want
to point out the autoscaling
that Spanner has.
There are multiple ways to
create the regional cluster,
the standard or the autopilot.
And then we handle both
zonal failures as well as
regional failures.
And knock on wood-- we have
not had a regional failure.
Same thing with
Spanner with Autoscaler
and multiregion configuration
and replication and DR--
all that is coming out
of the box for your use.
The data fabric itself,
like the lifecycle
of data from ingestion
to processing
to storing to analyzing and
then getting value out of it,
across the board with
security and governance
underlying all those
services is what we have.
Here is an
architecture that could
be data coming from a number
of sources in batch mode,
in streaming, real time,
structured, unstructured
data, semi-structured data.
We collect all of that
in a giant real-time,
time-series-ordered,
synchronized, distributed event
store built on top of Spanner.
If you don't have
the requirements
that Spanner needs,
like you don't need
that strong consistency,
but you need
very low latency and a
very high throughput,
this architecture will
also work on Bigtable.
You then give it to
the data services
that you could be running in
GKE to do your processing.
You can give it to BigQuery
to do the pattern analytics
and to run those BQML models.
Or archive it in
Google Cloud Storage
because for a lot
of industries, there
are requirements to keep
the data for 7 years, 10
years, or life long,
like in health care.
And you can explore the data
on the dashboards using Looker.
So this entire
range of services--
here is a reference
architecture for data fabric
that we will be building.
OK now, here are some
of the requirements
across the industries.
So for retail, you definitely
need the performance
at scale, especially on a
Black Friday, Cyber Monday.
You also need a single source of
truth across all the channels.
Whether you are ordering it
with your app or on the web
or in the store, if it tells
you, Ajaya, you have 25 doors.
I don't need 25 doors,
25 hinges, right?
Then I should be
able to get those 25
hinges at a consistent price.
It should not be that different
channels are giving me
different prices, right?
I should be able to
shop any time I need.
I don't want to see
"come back later," right?
Every retailer will tell you
what's the cost of downtime.
And most of them have
staff trained in ANSI SQL,
so having that with
Spanner definitely helps.
Similar requirements
with gaming--
hundreds of very
popular game needs
to manage hundreds of
VMs, thousands of VMs,
and you don't want to
be doing that manually.
And the game, especially
with multiplayer
games located in different
countries-- the games
have to be available
at all times, at scale,
and not cost you a [INAUDIBLE]
Fintech, again, all of those,
as well as availability, as well
as compliance, as well as strong
consistency in a distributed
environment across multiple
geographic regions--
all of that.
So here is another
architecture very
similar to the data
fabric architecture.
You could be doing your banking
from any of these sources.
You write your APIs.
You have your transactional
apps running on top of Spanner.
The transaction goes out
to the payment gateway,
which hinges a doorway
to the payment processor
or the core banking, a
legacy core banking system.
There is security and
governance underneath all this.
And then you can
run your analytics
and collect the data
in a data warehouse.
This architecture is actually
working at multiple customers.
Our typical winning
profile has been--
and this is what
I mean to say is,
why did these customers in
these segments chose Spanner?
In the gaming,
strong consistency.
Leaderboard requires very
strong consistency, right?
If I'm the leader, I'm
the top of the game,
I want to be there, right?
A very popular game has
to scale immediately.
And when there is
no usage, it has
to scale down automatically.
It got to be available.
Someone is playing in Taiwan.
Someone is playing in Argentina.
It got to be available
at all times.
You have no tolerance
for downtime,
got to be able to
change your schema
and manage your
shards automatically.
Finserv, all of that, plus very
strong consistent transactions,
no tolerance for RPO, right?
No tolerance for that.
Autoscale some of the
performance scales where 23
million customers doing 25
million transactions a day
at 10-millisecond-or-less
latency.
In the retail, same thing--
multiregion, consistency,
availability.
I'm just a broken record
saying that over and over
and over again.
But those are the
product capabilities.
In addition, what
customers have enjoyed
working with us in Google
Cloud is the deep dive
that we do mutually
in collaboration
with our customers
on the capabilities
and on the roadmap.
We'll do architecture
review to tell them,
OK, swing this way or
this way because something
is coming on the roadmap.
And very early engagement
with the Google architects
and engineers-- all
that helps nail down.
So in addition to
those segments,
we also have health
care customers
running their EMR records,
doing the payments,
being compliant because
we are HIPAA compliant,
keeping the patient data, the
images, all in Spanner and GCS.
Real-time decision-making,
optimizing the routes
in real time--
that's low-latency,
high-transaction throughput.
All those applications
can run on Cloud Spanner.
And this is not an
exhaustive list of use cases.
These are just some
of the popular ones
running on Cloud Spanner today.
So Spanner is seeing
a lot of momentum.
You will recognize some
of these brand names
in different segments.
Gartner recognizes it.
But most importantly, we have
not reached here overnight.
We have had a long journey.
Today, we are handling
trillions of requests an hour,
over exabytes of data volume
and thousands of databases.
And basically, with the
innovation happening at Google,
this is basically
enabling customers
to future-proof
their businesses.
That's the part I want
to leave you with.
I'm going to be here
for some more time
to answer any questions
that you may have.
But I really want to thank
you for your time today.
I know all of you
are extremely busy.
I appreciate you coming
here and listening to this,
and I'm here to
answer your questions.
Thank you again.
And in order to ask a question,
you can either raise your hand,
and I'll call you out, or
you can unmute and ask away.
And if nothing is
there, then I will
be happy to give us
all some time back.
ROY FULLER: Yes, I'll
give it a few seconds
just to see if anyone's
going to ask a question.
And if not, I will
end the recording.
All right, so it
looks like it was
very thorough, no questions.
So thank you so much, Ajaya,
and thank you, everyone,
for joining.
I will end the
recording right now.
AJAYA GUMMADI:
Thank you, everyone.
ROY FULLER: Thank you.
AJAYA GUMMADI: Have a wonderful
rest of the week and weekend.
ROY FULLER: Thank you, you too.